posted a photo of you watching you know
the chief celebration in 2021 and that's
a hard that's a hard moment to be in
like confetti dropping for you to like
sit here and like take that [ __ ] on the
chin I mean that shows you like you got
some resolve and I showed you like bro
you knew like I'm gonna be back here
yeah as I see it like I said I got The
Perfect story you know I got traded here
things are going great we got a good
team we got a great quarterback we going
to the show in that moment it was
definitely something that was
heart-wrenching something that like it
hurt me the most because to see
everything go right and then in one of
the biggest moments for us to get to the
next level I'm saying that's that's why
I aspire to be I want to play in the
Super Bowl I want to do everything I can
I fell short of it and I felt like I
didn't do enough it's a team game yeah
I'm saying it's not just one person you
got a great support in cash yes I want
to do everything I can for this team but
be you you know saying I had to I had to
be like be you I'm saying Play Your Role
whatever it is you know I'm saying
whatever a game requires you just beat
up like and don't try to bite off more
than you can true because you can't do
everybody's job I'm saying that state
job and they do a great job at it so why
not just trust them